[Aplausos]
[Música]
en medio de una de las crisis políticas
económicas sociales e incluso judiciales
más importantes de la última década el
país más extenso y poblado de toda
américa latina se prepara para celebrar
elecciones generales el próximo mes de
octubre
es entonces cuando el actual presidente
de la república federativa de brasil
michel temer deberá hacerse a un lado y
dejar un cargo que asumió sin elecciones
mediante si así es brasil es un país
democrático desde 1988 pero en 2016 ante
graves acusaciones de irregularidades y
corrupción un juicio político un
impeachment resuelto con un abrumador
voto favor tanto en la cámara de
diputados como en el senado removió del
cargo a la entonces presidenta y líder
del partido de los trabajadores dilma
rousseff
[Música]
pública
presidente tras la expulsión de la
presidenta rousseff del palacio de la
aurora la residencia oficial del
presidente de brasil el cargo pasó a
manos de su vicepresidente michel temer
que la verdad no ha sido precisamente el
presidente brasileño más popular durante
estos dos años al frente de brasil temer
se ha enfrentado a una ola de
descontento social a grandes brotes de
violencia y a una intensa crisis
económica
vamos en otras palabras que a día de hoy
casi podemos decir que temer tiene más
probabilidades de ir convocado con la
selección brasileña de fútbol que de
regresar algún día al palacio
presidencial como inquilino claro
roberto mantener descender y cumplir la
construcción conservar las leyes
promover el bien del auto brasilero
sustentar la unión la integridad y la
independencia de brasil pero amigos
ahora el momento de la verdad ha llegado
con un nuevo presidente un nuevo
vicepresidente un nuevo congreso una
nueva mayoría en el senado y una nueva
elección o reelección de gobernadores
brasil debe escoger un nuevo rumbo pero
qué es exactamente lo que se está
jugando brasil pues antes de responder a
esta pregunta
necesitamos haceros una advertencia si
únicamente tuviéramos en cuenta las
circunstancias políticas a día de hoy el
futuro de brasil parecería menos
prometedor que la carrera política de
bush
descanso
[Música]
wisco
si ese candidato que se gastó una
fortuna 14 millones de dólares para
lograr apenas un 25 por ciento de los
votos en el caucus de iowa
vamos que cada persona que le votó le
salió por dos mil cuatrocientos dólares
que se dice pronto
veréis me explicó el candidato favorito
entre los brasileños el candidato que
lideraba todas las encuestas y que
ganaría sin dudar hoy las elecciones
tiene un problema y es que está ni más
ni menos que en chirona en la cárcel
hablamos como no de lula da silva
presidente de brasil entre 2003 y 2011
histórico dirigente del partido de los
trabajadores y uno de los líderes
políticos brasileños más importantes de
las últimas décadas ahora bien puede que
algunos estáis preguntando pero qué pasó
como una figura tan importante ha
terminado en prisión pues ni más ni
menos que venga seguro seguro que lo
acertáis por corrupción en 2015 un
tribunal del estado de paraná abrió una
investigación sobre un posible caso de
corrupción que involucraba al ex
presidente la operación conocida como el
la valla pto determinó que lula da silva
había recibido sobornos a cambio de
favorecer desde el gobierno mediante
contratos de empresas públicas a
compañías como odebrecht entre otras
constructoras
de esta forma amigos quien fue conocido
especialmente por sus programas sociales
que según se dice permitieron sacar de
la pobreza a 50 millones de brasileños
aunque la realidad es un poco diferente
cumple una pena de prisión de 12 años
por corrupción
y si a pesar de estar entre rejas con
una condena en firme por corrupción
lula ha seguido siendo el favorito de
los brasileños para el cargo de
presidente de la república cosas de la
política
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por cierto por si no lo sabéis o no
habéis caído lula no sólo está condenado
por corrupción sino que la propia dilma
rousseff la presidenta que fue expulsada
mediante impeachment fue la propia
sucesora de lula vamos que más que un
gobierno casi que parecía el atraco a un
banco por cierto un apunte si tenéis
netflix hay una serie bastante
interesante sobre todo esto túnel de
corrupción si podéis no os la perdáis
pero ahora bien no penséis que todo esto
fue sólo cosa de lula para nada
lo cierto es que brasil es un país que
tiene un serio problema con la
corrupción de hecho creo que podemos
decir que hay tres cosas que
principalmente frenan el despegue de
este coloso la violencia la burocracia y
la corrupción generalizada invertir en
brásil amigos no es una tarea nada
sencilla y tal vez esto es precisamente
lo que explica los difíciles momentos
por los que está atravesando el país
[Música]
se trata de la obra de la miel vamos a
continuar esta celebración
[Música]
brasil la eterna decepción
brasil el país de la samba y el carnaval
no levanta cabeza por cada año bueno hay
por lo menos tres años malos y claro así
no se puede de esta forma un país que
podría ser una próspera potencia padece
hoy una enorme fragilidad económica
política y social los últimos años son
buena prueba de ello fijaos los dos
anteriores presidentes fueron como hemos
dicho implicados en casos de corrupción
lula da silva y dilma rousseff pero es
que el actual presidente michelle temer
tampoco se libra tiene más que sospechas
a sus espaldas luego está el problema de
la violencia que ha crecido bastante
hasta unos niveles más que preocupantes
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
estamos hablando en 2017 se produjeron
más de 60.000 homicidios en brasil esto
supone más que la suma de los que se
producen en afganistán y en irak juntos
por otro lado la pobreza y el desempleo
han repuntado en los últimos años al
compás de una economía que no carbura
entre otras cosas porque el país
permanece excluido en gran medida del
comercio internacional porque pues por
una apuesta proteccionista y burocrática
un momento que son políticas que no
funcionan y que cuál es el problema la
prosperidad no llegará a todos pero anda
que a los políticos en fin todo este
desmadre es lo que explica a hechos como
este que se ha podido ver en todo el
planeta un voraz incendio destruye el
museo nacional de brasil el museo que
albergaba 20 millones de piezas
incluidos fósiles y momias no contaba
con sistema contra incendios amigos hoy
por hoy esto es brasil sin embargo un
momento las elecciones pueden suponer un
cambio de rumbo o tal vez no atentos
[Música]
la competición más importante
durante ni más ni menos que los últimos
22 años dos partidos políticos se han
repartido el gobierno de brasil el
partido de los trabajadores el partido
de lula da silva y el partido de la
socialdemocracia brasileña el psd r
ahora de cara a estos próximos comicios
viendo los resultados que han tenido lo
normal no sé sería esperar a que estos
dos partidos tratarán de dar un giro de
180 grados no os parece sin embargo nada
de eso por un lado el partido de los
trabajadores ha tratado por todos los
medios de presentar como candidato a
lula da silva ya total que esté en la
cárcel vamos a ver no os equivoquéis que
eso de aceptar sobornos oye lo mismo
supuso un enorme sacrificio para el
bueno de lula seguro seguro que os
podéis hacer una idea pero en serio no
se trata como he dicho antes de
enseñarse con lula desgraciadamente la
política brasileña es así de todas
formas finalmente el pasado 31 de agosto
de 2018 el tribunal electoral lo
confirmó de ninguna manera a lula podría
ser candidato pero claro dada la línea
que ha seguido el partido creo que no
podemos hablar de renovación y de cambio
nos parece
por otro lado el psdb ha presentado a
geraldo alckmin y aquí sí sorpresa
el candidato empezó la campaña con un
discurso digamos que centrado en sacar a
brasil del atolladero para ello anunció
no sólo que reduciría la carga fiscal y
mejoraría los incentivos a la inversión
sino que incluso tomaría como referencia
a las políticas que a principio de los
90 puso sobre la mesa el ex presidente
cardoso el protagonista tal vez de la
mayor etapa de prosperidad y cambio del
brazil en décadas
suena bien verdad pues amigos no
corramos tanto brasil es brasil de tal
manera que no han tardado en aparecer
noticias como esta fiscales brasileños
acusan a candidato presidencial al
coming por recibir fondos de odebrecht
ya sabéis siempre en la misma línea en
el mismo negocio con este panorama creo
que a nadie le cuesta entender por qué
los brasileños están perdiendo la
confianza en su sistema político y vamos
a ver que suele ocurrir cuando la
sociedad pierde esa confianza exacto es
el momento idóneo para movimientos
populistas o radicales y sabéis que
amigos eso es precisamente lo que parece
que está ocurriendo en este caso un
militar retirado un candidato con un
plan de medidas drásticas 6 bolsonaro se
ha convertido en la gran sorpresa de
estas elecciones
y eso qué bolsonaro es conocido por
frases y planteamientos tan reprobables
como estos no voy a combatir ni a
discriminar pero si veo a dos hombres
besándose en la calle les voy a pegar el
error de la dictadura fue torturar y no
matar veréis a día de hoy lo más
probable es que pase la segunda vuelta
del propio bolsonaro y fernando a dad el
sustituto de lula da silva la situación
ahora mismo es tan complicada que en el
marco de la enorme ola de violencia que
registra brasil durante un acto de
campaña bolsonaro recibió una puñalada
que le ha producido graves lesiones lo
que evidentemente le ha obligado a ser
hospitalizado y a continuar su campaña
principalmente por redes sociales el
motivo de tal polémica no es otro que
las propias características de este
ultra y radical político duro defensor
de la pena de muerte y de la
militarización de la política sus
críticos le tachan de ser xenófobo
homófobo autoritario y un auténtico
peligro para la democracia brasileña
ahora bien viendo todo esto que explica
el fuerte auge de este candidato en las
encuestas se debe su extraordinaria
intención de voto exclusivamente a un
voto crítico e indignado es algo así
como una moda pasajera pues ojo porque
en el despegue de bolsonaro tiene mucho
que ver el voto evangélico hasta tal
punto que puede que no estemos
simplemente ante un voto de protesta
sino tal vez ante una tendencia mucho
pero que mucho más sólida veréis brasil
es un país muy religioso por ejemplo
gracias a su tamaño es el país con más
católicos de todo el planeta unos 123
millones de personas profesan esta
religión sin embargo en las últimas
décadas está creciendo con fuerza de la
población evangélica según el último
censo los evangélicos suponen ya el 20
por ciento de la población del país una
de cada 5 personas más de 40 millones de
personas y por lo general los
evangélicos suelen ser un poquito más
conservadores y activistas de tal modo
que ya os podéis imaginar quién es su
candidato favorito si así es la
intención de voto del señor bolsonaro
entre la población de evangélica
8 y 10 punto superior a su apoyo entre
el conjunto de brasileños fijaos en
brasil necesitamos un macho como el
defender a todos los valores y
principios de la familia cristiana
silas malafaia uno de los pastores más
influyentes de brasil en fin amigos
veremos un cambio de verdad en brasil o
continuará el duopolio que ha regido los
destinos del país durante los últimos 22
años dará la campanada del radical
bolsonaro a algún otro candidato nuevo
no alineado con los dos grandes partidos
tal vez muy pronto lo sabremos de
momento todo apunta a una nueva victoria
en segunda vuelta del partido de los
trabajadores el partido de lula da silva
y dilma rousseff y la pregunta que nos
podemos hacer es realmente es otro
gobierno del partido de los trabajadores
lo mejor para brasil porque amigos si
algo está claro es que este país
necesita un cambio de rumbo y desde
luego no parece que más de lo mismo
pueda suponer un cambio de nada pero
ahora turno para ti del 1 al 5 qué
opinión tienes de lula da silva déjanos
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si el vídeo te
ha resultado interesante dale a like y
no olvides suscribirte aviso
polític por cierto muchas gracias a
nuestro amigo sebastián morales fuertes
por ayudarnos a preparar este vídeo un
saludo y hasta la próxima
no tuve tiempo 6
por cierto